at a high level
is there suggestions you can give on how
to take good notes
whether it's we're talking about
annotations or just for yourself to try
to
put on paper ideas as you progress
through the work in order to then like
understand the work better
for me i always try not to underestimate
how much you can forget uh within six
months right after you've read something
i thought you're going to say
five minutes but yeah six months is good
yeah or or even shorter and so
that's something i always try to keep in
mind and uh
and it's and it's often i mean every
once in a while i'll read back a
paper that i annotated on vermont and
it's and
uh and i'll read through my own
annotations and it's uh
and i've completely forgotten what i had
written and
but it also it it also it's interesting
because in a way
after you just understood something
you're kind of the best
possible teacher that can teach your
future
self uh yeah you know after you've
forgotten it
uh you can you're kind of your own best
possible teacher at that moment
and so it's it can be great to try to
capture that
it's it's brilliant it just made me kind
of
realize it's really nice to
to put yourself in the position of
teaching an older version of yourself
exactly that returns to this paper
almost like thinking it literally
that's underexplored but it's it's super
powerful because you were the person
that
you can like if you if you look at the
scale from like one
not knowing anything about the topic and
ten like you are the one that progressed
from one to ten and you know which
steps you struggled with so you're the
really the best person to help yourself
make that
transition from one to ten and um
a lot of the times like and we don't i
really believe that the framework there
we have to like expose ourselves to like
be talking to
like us when we were an expert when we
were taking that class and we knew
everything about quantum mechanics
and then six months later you don't
remember half of the things how could
we make it easier for like tweak have
those conversations between you and your
past
past expert self um i i think there
there might be you know it's an
underexplored idea i think
notes on paper are probably not the best
way i'm not sure if it's a combination
of like
video audio where it's like you have a
guided
framework that you follow to extract
information from yourself
so that you can later kind of revisit to
make it easier to
to remember but that's i think it's
an interesting idea worth worth
exploring that
not i've i haven't seen a lot of people
kind of trying to
uh distill that problem you know i'm
creating the kind of tools i find if i
record it sounds weird but i'll take
notes but
if i record audio like um like little
clips of
thoughts like rants
that's really effective at capturing
something that notes
can't because when i replay them for
some reason
it loads my brain back into where i was
when i was reading that
in a way that notes don't like when i
read notes
i'll often be like what what
what was i what was i thinking there but
when i listen to the audio yeah
it brings you right back to that place
so there might and maybe with video with
visual that might be even more powerful
i think so yeah and and i think just the
process of
you know verbalizing it that alone kind
of
makes you have to structure your thought
and and put it in a way that
somebody else could come and understand
it and and just the process of that is
useful
to to organize your thoughts and and and
um
yeah just just that alone does the
framaz library journal club have a
like a video component or no we no not
natively
we sometimes will include videos but
it's always embedded do people
like build videos on top of it to
explain the paper because you're doing
all the hard work
of understanding deeply the paper
not we haven't seen that happening too
much but
uh we were we were actually playing
around with the idea of
creating some sort of podcast version
where we tried to distill
the paper uh on an audio format that not
maybe you could have access might be
trickier but you
there are definitely people that could
be interested in the paper in that topic
but are not willing to read it
but they might listen to a 30-minute
episode on that paper
yes you could reach more people and and
you might even bring the authors to the
conversation but it's tricky
especially for like more technical
papers we've we've thought about
that doing that but we haven't uh like
converged sure if you have any uh well
i'm gonna take that as a small project
to take one of you one of the formats
almost like
half advertisement and half as a
challenge for myself to take to take one
of the annotated papers and like use it
as a basis for creating a
a quick video i i i've seen like um
hopefully i'm saying the name correctly
but machine learning street talk
i think that's the name of the show the
that i recommend highly
that's the right thing but uh they they
do exactly that which is multiple hour
breakdown of a paper with video
component
sometimes with authors people love it
it's very effective
there's there's also i've seen i haven't
seen the entire
in its entirety but i've seen like the
the founder of
comma george yeah i've seen him like
just
taking a paper and then uh you know
distilling the paper
and and coding it coding it sometimes
during 10 hours
yeah and he was able to you know get a
lot of people interested in in that and
viewing
him so i'm a huge fan of that
like uh george is a personality i think
a lot of people like listen to this
podcast for the same reason
it's not necessarily the contents it's
they they they like to listen to like a
a silly russian who has a childlike
brain and
mumbles and all those like struggle with
ideas right
and george is a madman people just enjoy
like
how is he going to struggle in
implementing this particular paper how
is he going to struggle with this idea
it's fun to watch and that actually
pulls you in
the personality is important there true
but there's lots there's
you know i agree with you but they're
also it's visible like it's
there's an extraordinary ability that is
there like is
talented and you need to have there's a
craft and
this guy definitely has talent and he's
doing something that is not easy
and i think that also draws the
attention of people oh yeah and
and like the other day we were actually
we ran into this youtube channel of this
guy that was restoring art right um yeah
and and um it was basically just a video
of him like his
the production is really like really
well done and it's just
him taking really old pieces of art like
and then paintings and then restoring
them but he's really good at that and he
describes that process and
that draws attention draws the attention
of people regardless of your craft
be it like annotating your paper or like
responsibilities
excellence yeah like george is
incredibly good at programming
like quick like you know those uh
competitive programmers like
top motor and all those kinds of stuff
he has the same kind of element where
the brain just jumps
around really quickly and that's uh yeah
just like it's hard inspiration it's
more yeah it's motivating but
but and you're right in in watching
people
who are good at what they do it's
motivating even if the thing you're
trying to do is not what they're doing
it's just like contagious when they're
really good at it
and the same kind of analysis with the
paper i think
so not just like the final result but
the process yeah
struggling with it that's really
interesting yeah i think i mean i think
twitch proved that like
yeah you know that there's really a
market for for that for watching
people do things that they're really
good at and
and you'll just watch it you'll enjoy
that that that might even
spike your interest in that specific
topic and
yeah and people people will enjoy
watching sometimes hours on end
of great craftsmen
you